can I pick up right where we left off
and we did some fancy geometric footwork
and we prove this limit do you remember
this limit what do you we are what do
you find we send with one right which
means that what is a special number
because it is it's a reciprocal so not
only is this litter equal to one but the
reciprocal afternoon the reciprocal
gives us the same value okay because
what is it so what we're going to do is
we're going to carry this forward are
not going to read investigate the
personal we're gonna carry it forward
into a couple of other results and then
see how we can i will look at sabbatical
starting some more time to do so so this
is already the box you can prepare your
color box around it let's extend it down
okay you remember can we begin looking
at that circle and there was the sector
inside it there was the triangle inside
it and then there was that triangle
outside it which did not have to do with
Siberian Qatar it has to do with 10
people and so is this the reason that I
should be able to bring this in a little
way so for me the best way to bring tan
in to plate up is to use this as my
first line so if I think about that
limit I can say well as their approaches
0 for small values of theta slightly
heart is very close to isn't funny the
only difference between side and
is what is the displacement silent a
fighting for its / cars right so
therefore i can rewrite sine as 10 times
close do you agree with that like that
sine theta 0 cos theta times cos theta
mestre cancel out and give that sign so
i am rewriting sine theta in that form
okay now keep in mind because this is
that exactly the same as this just
reject a little bit it's still equal to
the same value yes okay excuse me take
this with me though because if you think
all the way back to where we first
introduced limits and I know this is a
while ago so if you forgot this that's
okay you might remember that we've gone
a product of two limits and that's what
this is this is the limit as the Year
approaches zero of this times this
the limit of a product is in fact the
product of two limiting treatment quite
separately this is different to
derivatives let me do some limits on
their own theme okay so this is the
limit as your approaches 0 of this ratio
times are all of you liveth obk right
treating the cosine on its own terms but
of course this we kind of took advantage
of this trick before this is wonderful
because this right here bit here this is
really simple isn't it what is happening
to cosine s top-20 where's it going
right it's coming up to one right think
about the cosine graph looks like there
it is right it's an even function so
this guy is just going to be equal to
one just like over there by the way I
would like to encourage you whenever
you're using these limits or if you do a
limit like this please even though x one
doesn't change sign please indicate to
me that you are multiplying by one right
it's a difference between a term
disappearing and it's her becoming
something that will then end up
disappearing what I valuator
this is me showing I understand what's
happening to this limit it's all that I
ignore it it's that it's something
that's something now remember we said
that this style is just a rewriting of
this so when I evaluate it because I
care about it's just equal to the left
hand side it's just equal to one so this
tells me now I bring it all together
because now I've got 10 Peter and Peter
by themselves I'll put this in a box
that the limit as he approaches zero of
not just sign here on the arm but tan
theta ikea also equal to 1 and that
means because again and what is its own
reciprocal i can turn this upside down
yeah
why is legends I want great question see
where this left-hand side camera right
where it really came from was be
rewriting this to try and squeeze tan
right so sign is 10 * cotton so this
whole thing here is exactly the same as
this whole thing here which is one glad
you clarified that yep sorry oh why the
hospital on theater
become because the
okay so you can see here right all I've
done he is just tease out because they
that show you you're actually dealing
with something times something else i
mislike dislike the limit of a product
is the product of the limits yeah okay
fantastic so now i've got this i can
turn upside down just in the same way
that I did here so the liver as theater
efficiency road of all the reciprocal
also equal to one and that's one of the
box around okay excellent now this is
very very theoretical right what you're
doing is you're comparing these things
together and you're saying look when
fear is really tiny when you're getting
close to the origin these things are
going to get closer and closer and
closer to time okay so draw for me just
a little picture of this if we draw the
first quadruped and we draw sine theta
feet up and tear the other and this is
what they're all going to look like I
can do three colors
I'm really interested in small values of
this I'm not even going to go past prior
to thinking in radians mode because
remember the original geometric
construction that we did this on I had
to have acute angles right so how far
does safety to go it starts the origin
what does it get to by the time he gets
the
it gets up to 1 and then it stops there
right so I'm just going to draw that
little part of Celia so there is
now what does 10 feet of a [ __ ]
um it's got this asymptote of pilots who
doesn't it can't get there it gets
steeper and steeper and steeper so if I
put it on the same graph it's going to
look something like that
said oh yeah have you know that doesn't
go ah that's a great question how do we
know that it cannot and will not ever in
mr. name goes underneath
think back yeah
going
yep but Erica Gotti yet little started
one is
yes good
start the staying warm enough
okay so let's just rehearse that for a
second kitchen catcher right they're
both doing the same kind of behavior
they're both approaching and I'm
actually missing something to be on the
line in between is Thea and it's a
straight line so there is our theater is
Tam Peter and this st. Peter okay so
you've got this guy which is just local
cavity this one is concave up so that's
like curves away oops and this is
concave down so it also curves way up in
the other direction there's another way
to see it and you may need to just turn
back to yesterday's work before we got
to this there was an inequality that
preceded this do you remember what the
inequality was had three pieces to it
remember i think if we get a right it
should be sine theta is less than
food art which is less than 10 thean do
you remember what these represented they
represented a triangle inside a circle
the sector and the triangular went
outside the circle and look at this when
theater is a cute you can't break this
right so that means this is always
underneath this is always in the middle
and that is always above that's exactly
what that entails okay brilliant so
let's use this before we move on to some
more like application the application
let's look at a pretty algebraic
applications we got three three of these
forms